and curry is sharing unique stories of
people who are searching for someone
from their past the veteran journalist
is back on television with the program
called we'll meet again
it focuses on reunions between people
whose lives intersected and were torn
apart at a pivotal moment in world
history like the Vietnam War or the
September 11th attacks well the first
episode documents a japanese-american
woman sent to an internment camp in
World War two she's searching for the
childhood friend who stood by her I was
frightened and she made everything all
worthwhile when all the other kids were
mean to me she was my friend you know
you feel an obligation to thank her
after all these years it says something
about how much it meant to you that she
stood up for you I owe something to the
children that I've told the story to
about how painful it is to think about
maybe I'll die and not ever be able to
say thank you
we gotta find Mary Frances we'll meet
again executive producer and reporter
Ann Curry joins us again only on CBS
this morning
welcome back to the table oh I want to
start with that picture and curry a
little Mary Frances and Reiko Wright
reuniting after all this time and when I
saw this series we'll meet again it felt
so you to me oh it did it really
resonated when we started talking about
the idea I mean it struck me because you
know I've spent you know a career
covering world-changing events and this
is about how people react in
world-changing movements how they how
they can reach out and do something an
act of kindness and sometimes even more
be heroic and rescue each other and how
they can help save their lives
emotionally as well as physically and so
just it just resonated with me something
you said could really say well your mom
is Japanese and your dad is American and
you were thinking about how the two of
them were separate not in the internment
camp but the two of them had a little
separation - that's right I think maybe
that's one reason why absolutely right
why it really resonated my parents were
my father was an occupation soldier my
mother was a war bride she was a they
were both 18 years old they fell in love
and and my father went to the Navy and
said you know I want to marry this woman
but at that time couldn't marry a
Japanese woman so the Navy said Bob your
eyes are starting to slant
no you're turning into a bamboo American
they actually said that but I think that
they were trying to help him not commit
to something at 18 years old so they
sent him to Morocco for two years and he
kept trying to get back and they
wouldn't let him come back so finally he
came back and he went to my mother's my
mother was a rice farmer's daughter way
up in the mountains you know fast troop
home and found her and then that reunion
they were sobbing and hugging and then
he stepped away because he realized
something was wrong she had she found
out because she was so skeletal that she
was dying of tuberculosis oh and at this
point you could marry a Japanese woman
but you couldn't marry sick one
but that's why reunions resonate with
you as well exactly and so they got
together and so yeah that's it the story
goes on from there but probably don't
have time to say you know and one of the
interesting things to about we'll meet
again and this series made me think
about people that I want to go back and
meet from my childhood it's hard it was
hard for you to create these reunions
and find people right right exactly it
really is I really think that with the
internet we could just find anybody we
want but actually not so much I mean
there's a lot of you know excavation
that has to happen talking to librarians
and genealogists and so absolutely it's
hard and it's amazing these small brief
moments in people's lives occupy then
this great space in their life they fill
it with so much meaning and import even
after 75 years exactly in the case that
you just saw the clip that you just saw
these women have been waiting for more
than 70 years to see each other and what
was really amazing is that Mary Francis
doesn't remember the very tall woman
compared to little short Reiko doesn't
remember what she had done but what she
had done was showed friendship at a time
when other kids were throwing rocks and
adults were saying bad things to all
japanese-americans at in these in
certain communities because of the
bombing of Pearl Harbor and so this
little girl on the right of your screen
Mary Frances she reached out to Reiko
she showed her ways being friends when
she came back from the internment camps
it was Mary Frances that walked up to
her grabbed her hand and pulled her into
the playground so this is my friend and
she doesn't even
number married Francis doesn't remember
what she did and so the idea that we
could commit an act of kindness that
might change someone's life and to sort
of have her be surprised by Waco saying
thank you so much I mean it was just
lovely watched them reunite we had our
headsets on we were trying to stay away
a little bit back from them so that they
could really have that moment although
we wanted to honor that respect that and
we were all sobbing including the
cameramen there was another amazing
moment when you're with Raiko at the
internment camp in Montana was it where
she's thinking about her parents she
wasn't sad for herself but the impotence
her parents felt having their family be
taken to this place and have to make a
life exactly you know Rico was born in
America and she said I couldn't control
my country for my parents our parents
were immigrants and that they suffered
so much because they were suffering
because their kids were suffering in
that little as you can see in that
screen where they were staying inside
the internment camp and she was going
she went back to the very room the very
building where it happened where they
were staying for so long so yeah I think
that you know what you see is history
not just from the point of view of
presidents and generals you hear this
history from the point of view of the
common man and woman and how they were
caught up in it and how they needed each
other to survive and I actually think
this is the story of all of us because
then out throughout all of our ancestors
there were people who had to survive
these kinds of world-changing events and
it was because of others whether their
their families or strangers that we even
exist so I think this is a story of all
of us it's also a nice history lesson
for different events Mount st. Helens
the explosion there I was very touched
by 9/11 in that story it's because a
woman gave a survivor a hug she didn't
realize because she said you look like
you need a hug she did not realize the
impact that that hug had on that man's
life all these years later and he wanted
to find her exactly wanted to find her
because he was actually in the hotel
between the two towers and barely
escaped with his life she they met at
the situs in high school where she was a
photographer's assistant and she just
saw him slumped up against the wall and
said you look like you needed a hug and
she took care of him she's this young
twentysomething he's a businessman from
the Midwest you know and
she essentially took care of him he was
so of course traumatized by what he had
experienced she walked him out she made
sure he was fed she didn't let him out
of her sight until she knew that he had
someplace to go and so he wanted to say
thank you for this and it's just so
slowly and some of the stories are about
true heroism where somebody actually
comes in and rescue someone and
sometimes there's these stories that we
talk about about ultimate just the
kindness that we can each show for
another and how this can have an impact
that we may not even fully know well we
know all your kindness and thank you for
sharing it great to see you back on TV
we're gonna see more more after these
six episodes Maureen well you know
there's been there they're already in
development yes thank you I think you're
gonna let it by request two of people do
do someone in their lives who they want
to meet again so I yeah thank you guys
it's been great to sit with you thank
you thank you Andy and we'll meet again
premieres Tuesday on PBS January 23rd
and you can hear more from Anne in this
week's issue of People magazine as well